i never thought i would agree with aoc
i never thought i really never thought i
would agree with aoc
on something like the george floyd case
the trial of derrick chauvin
for the not not just the killing of
george floyd the murder of george floyd
and yet aoc and i agree on a very narrow
point
we agree that the verdict that the jury
reached
was unjust so no
this verdict is not justice
frankly i don't even think we call it
full accountability
because there are
multiple officers that were there
it wasn't just just derek chauvin
and i also don't want this moment
to be framed as this system working
working because it's not working
and
that's what creates a lot of complexity
in this moment
that's what creates a lot of complexity
what's the complexity the verdict is
just or it's unjust i think it's unjust
aoc seems to think it's unjust so good
we'll get rid of it on appeal right
maybe i don't think that's exactly what
she's saying on this narrow point though
aoc is right
for all the wrong reasons you heard aoc
mention this distinction between justice
and accountability and you're going to
hear the left
make this distinction a lot over the
next few days it's kind of like this
distinction that they're making between
equality and equity
and on the one hand these distinctions
are meaningless they're distinctions
without a difference
but i i do think actually that there is
some
worthwhile distinction here between
accountability and justice usually
usually what the left does
when they coin new terms like this or
when they put a lot of emphasis on one
term over another
is they say look obviously this isn't
justice this was mob rule here the total
overwhelming of the judicial system the
guy was convicted in the media not
in a court of law however
we need to still say that it's sort of
like just so we're just going to make a
new term
equality well we're going to make a new
term equity and we like equity and we
hate equality well here what's the
difference
between accountability and justice
i think the subtle difference here is
that justice
refers to an eternal
objective concept right justice refers
to
the moral law which is eternally true
whatever we all think here on earth even
if we act very unjustly
like the sort of injustice we saw
yesterday in the derek shoven trial
accountability is a little different
accountability is like
responsiveness to people
so when when you're talking about
there's no accountability i think
it very subtly plays into this radical
subjectivism
that you're seeing from the left and
especially from people like aoc on the
left
which is that look there are no eternal
standards we're going to remake the
whole system
we're going to upend the entire moral
order
we're going to flip society inside out
and the only standard that will matter
is what we think we the people who make
the standards
you you will not have to worry about
justice and
account of accountability to god you
just you'll just worry about
accountability meaning you know
responsiveness
to me to us we
the radical leftists who are going to
remake the world by redefining all the
terms
that i it's a it's a subtle distinction
but i do think that's what is at play
here
that the left is ultimately interested
this is why they don't want to say that
justice was served here
in the case of derek chovin is because
what they're ultimately interested in
is not reforming the police system or
reforming the justice system a little
bit
that is completely disingenuous when
they say that they want to undo the
whole thing they're saying the entire
country is rotten to the core and it
won't be set right until
they are in power and they get to remake
everything and even then it's going to
be a perpetual revolution
this is what the left always does it's
why fidel castro was wearing his
military fatigues
until he was 92 years old because the
revolution is still
going on doesn't matter that castro held
power for 60 years
no there's still more work to do viva
siempre la revolucion
that i think is what is at play here
it's why it's so important to pay
very close attention to these little
words is
when when you accept the left's new
language you accept whole premises here
whoa whoa whoa whoa where are you going
where hold on you don't need to leave so
fast
first please ring the bell ring the bell
subscribe that way you will never miss a
video that we put out
something tells me that sometimes
youtube would prefer it if you would
miss videos that we put out
so make sure you subscribe like really
appreciate it we'll see on the next
[Music]
[Music]